today's brilliant is sponsored by video
today's video is going to be a
simple one as requested by a surprising
number of people
on my twitter i'm going to be talking
about the books on my shelves that's
going to be both here on the set but
also downstairs in our
private collection that makes it sound a
lot grounder than it really is we don't
have
i mean we have a fair number of books
but like not that many compared to some
people if you're a long time viewer of
this channel then yes you will have seen
quite a few of these books before
but there are some favorites that i
don't think i've ever talked about
and there's also a couple of stories
about some books that i'd like to share
so let's kick off with let's start over
here
this is a rough collection of some of my
favorites that i wanted to put up on the
top shelf so that they could appear in
videos basically
and you will have already seen several
of these before i've made a whole video
about sapiens uh don't even think about
it uninhabitable earth and merchants of
doubt recently appeared in a video about
my
favorite reads about climate change a
couple of extra little bits at the top
here we have
six easy pieces now this is a really
battered copy
because it's quite old i received this
i don't know i'll have to get a close-up
of this later in 2008
as part of a prize that i won at the
oxford summer school so i went to a
summer school for
state school kids who wanted to apply to
do physics at oxford and
i i think i was part of a team that won
a prize i don't think it was an
individual one and i
took this with me to the pyrenees i did
a two-week expedition to the pyrenees
uh climbing some mountains with some
people from school
and uh this was just roughed around in
my my
rucksack for ages and it was one of
those books it's much like uh when i did
a video about a brief history of time
that uh it kind of just makes you fall
in love with physics feynman is
a fantastic science communicator
slightly spicy taking coming i actually
don't think the feynman lectures are
good as a first introduction to physics
i think that
the books are great to hook people in
but if you actually want to learn the
subjects you should go read other
textbooks
where fyman excels and it's probably
more true for six not so easy pieces
actually
is if you already know the subject
matter you read it and you think
that is a really clever explanation of
it that's really elegant the way he's
done that but it's not necessarily the
best introduction to it two other books
i just want to quickly highlight are
these two
so zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance and the strangest man
so zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance i think i read when i was
about 15 16
um and it was one of the most
influential books on me i think this
book kind of defined my personal
philosophy and the nature of
quality what it means to have quality as
a person
and yeah i've it's one of these books
that i've been afraid to reread because
i enjoyed it so much the first time i'm
scared that i'd read it again and it
wouldn't be as good definitely not for
everyone
uh it's it's quite a weird structure to
be honest but it's
uh oh it's a lid from a takeaway that i
used as a
paper mug what the other one the
strangest man by graham formula is the
best biography i've ever
read uh paul derek was a fascinating guy
he was one of the greatest physicists of
the 20th century and he also came from
bristol
which is my hometown of the area and um
he was just astonishing and the book
captures
him and his work very very well you
don't have to be a physicist to
understand this
it's it's just one of the great
biographies i think i
genuinely think that everybody should
read this next this little cluster of
books so
like that other section this has a
couple of favorites some which i've made
videos about relatively recently such as
the discovery of global warming
and this changes everything paired up
with zen in the art of motorcycle
maintenance for sort of defining
or awakening kind of philosophical ideas
in me i'd also like to put
brave new world this is a tiny tiny copy
this was actually given to me by an
ex-girlfriend
i first read brave new world when i was
10 which is
far too young i think um seeing as
there's a lot of
a lot of nudity in sex in this thing man
this actually explains
quite a lot but it was the book that
told me that just because something is
logical doesn't mean it is morally
correct and i think that was quite an
important lesson for me to learn at that
age
not sure this was the right way to do it
of the two famous dystopias i massively
prefer brave new world to 1984. i think
this is a lot more prescient
i've got to be very careful this video
doesn't become an hour long
uh but just a couple of other ones i
want to highlight quickly uh
infinitesimal by amir alexander i don't
think i've made a video about this i
might have done
this is one of the best non-fiction
books i've read um i think i put this up
here because this
in a way define what i think a good
non-fiction book should be
it is really quite dense actually that's
the one thing that it has against it
it's not the most accessible thing
um what this is is a history of the
development of infinitesimal calculus
basically this idea of
a structure in mathematics that is so
small that it doesn't exist like it's
infinitely small
and that was a heretical idea and
um it developed in tandem in italy
and in england and uh what happened kind
of defined a lot of
where the scientific revolution took
place really uh
and it's just so good such a good book
another title that had a massive
influence on me uh i don't think it's
quite as good
as infinitesimal but a brief history of
medicine i read this as part of my
history gcse we did a whole year which
was just
medicine from prehistory to modern times
and this was a book that i think my mum
bought for me actually
um sort of just as background reading
and
it's just really good i'm currently
reading the emperor of all maladies
which is a biography of cancer
and it definitely reminds me of this um
that is better
for sure emperor formalities won a
pulitzer prize for a reason it's
so well written and then lastly up here
i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
my simpsons bible i got this when i was
a kid and this is i think seasons
one to nine i wanna say
one to eight seasons one to eight which
means that it does not contain the day
the simpsons died which was the
arm in tanzarian the principle and the
pauper episode and you can see from how
like like battered this is i devoured
this book as a kid
every time i watched an episode of the
simpsons like flaming moe's
you'd go to the book you know learn who
the guest stars were
pick up all the stuff you might have
missed uh remembering the key quotes
this is why
if people have watched me you're
streaming with the oxcast for example my
brain is 90
simpsons references next up is a group
of books that you don't actually
see on camera i don't think but this is
effectively what i use for reference a
lot of the time so
one of the reasons i built this set was
because i wanted to have something
different in the background of my videos
but also
something practical so i actually have
storage for things like we'll get to
we'll get to this i have practical
storage for the books that i use pretty
much on a daily basis so if i'm writing
a script or if i'm working on claude
i will very often turn to this section
the book that i use probably most
frequently for this
is atmospheric science and introductory
survey by wallace and hobbs
this is basically an undergraduate
introductory textbook to
everything to do with the atmosphere so
that's synoptic scale stuff
small scale stuff oceanic stuff uh kind
of everything all in one place
because here's the thing a lot of what i
do
is not high level it's not something
that you need graduate level textbooks
for like yes i will read papers that are
about specific topics
but for the purposes of a youtube video
or the level that claude is currently
operating at
we only need the basic stuff and this is
a really good introductory textbook
for that if anybody is interested in
getting into atmospheric science if you
like my videos but you want to learn
more about the quantitative side this is
a really good place to start
next to that however we do have the big
kahuna this is
valas's atmospheric and oceanic fluid
dynamics and
sections of this book still scare me uh
i used this book
a lot during the phd oh a waterstones
card with a stamp on it oh that was pl
that was place marking planetary waves
in the stratosphere
one of the most important bits of my
thesis and basically this is if i ever
have
a higher level question about something
to do with atmospheric science this is
where i'll go there is actually as we'll
see later there is an essentials version
of this which is much thinner and
far more suited to somebody who's just
coming to the field but if you
really need a quantitative answer for a
particular equation
or if there's something that i'm
planning in the future for claude this
is where it's at it's not just
atmospheric science though there's a lot
of other stuff here there's a couple of
books sort of to do with history
generally longitude and eureka
about sort of the development of science
in the greek and early modern period
the master algorithm which i have made a
video about i believe about
machine learning and various other
references including
oh what's this notices your thesis
squeezes these are a bunch of reports
from the renewable energy network so
about
asia and the pacific sort of the state
of renewable
energy the future of renewable energy
that kind of thing which is very
very useful to have to put figures into
videos oh just quickly
jetstream by tim willings is a really
nice little introduction to certain
parts of atmospheric dynamics it's
definitely slim it's less than 200
pages um but it covers a surprising
amount uh you actually come away with a
pretty good sense of certainly the jet
stream but also with some other aspects
of the atmosphere
um would you recommend incidentally by
the way if you're interested in
the hobby uh which is also behind me
that's my miniatures cabinet then
definitely check out the videos on my
second channel simon clark errata where
i do a monthly painting update and i'm
also in
i think the next week gonna be doing a
video where i just sort of showcase
all of my armies so that includes the
planes from aeronautica my
tyranids i need to build the hive tyrant
still magnetize it i'm a bit scared and
my space marines and of course my
uh hawaiian orcs has made famous on
twitch probably about the bottom third
of this entire setup by the way is hobby
material like
sprays bits boxes uh boxes of sprues
or all that kind of stuff it's it's all
here anyway the last two books that i
wanted to just quickly mention here are
mad midlab spirit dynamics uh which is
like the bible for stratospheric
dynamics
uh and concepts in thermal physics by
blundell and blundell this
uh was written by my favorite lecturer
ever stephen blundell at oxford
uh i've never seen anybody lecture quite
like him he was
just so good and this is an example of a
textbook that i used at undergraduates
and i liked so much that uh i think it
was
during the phd actually i bought myself
a copy because
it's just a useful reference to have but
on that note
over here we have the last section of
books which contains a number of
textbooks so a lot of these are
textbooks that i
used as an undergraduate and i want it
for whatever reason so
riley hobson and bentz is the bible when
it comes to undergraduate mathematics
and i actually use this sometimes i
still do need to look up a couple of
things
this is the textbook i recommend to
people if you're going to go off to do
physics or engineering
at university this is like the one mass
textbook you'll ever need
next to that we see the essentials of
atmospheric oceanic dynamics which is
the
slim version of the valles that i showed
you earlier and this is to be honest
this is the version i actually probably
consult more frequently because it's
easier to find what i'm looking for two
other excellent textbooks that i bought
because i just wanted them
strogatz non-linear dynamics and chaos
one of my favorite books as an
undergraduate
and rindler's relativity i found this to
be the most
sensible introduction to tenses because
this is special and
general relativity and i would love to
start using this in videos but i
would really need to go on a crash
course of maths to do that and speaking
of that
this is quantum field theory in a
nutshell by z
and this was the book that my
theoretical physics major option at
oxford
used uh for the quantum field theory
stuff
and if i'm honest i never really got it
i um i used perhaps a chapter or two
and went into my head but i was in a
very bad place
personally like you know in terms of my
mental health at that time and this kind
of just impacted on the surface
and i've always wanted to go back to
this book
and i've always said that you know i
will
do that perhaps that's a video actually
just just spitballing
if people would like to see me like
wrestle with this and maybe do a video
of you know i give myself a month to try
and learn this book and i have to teach
it to you
maybe that's i don't know comment if
you'd like to see that but this is
almost a white whale
type thing uh i i remember liking the
textbook it's very
accessibly written i love the layout
it's just
a hard subject and then finally in this
section uh gcse spanish because
that was when i was originally dating
pixel girl and i was trying to impress
her by learning spanish
um except no hablo espanol
now and there's this little slim book
which is on
spin waves now i know nothing about spin
waves i don't want to know anything
about spoon waves
but this was a prize i won this in uh
2012 for winning the gibbs prize
uh in the physics department in oxford
so i gave a talk on a brief history of
pie
which was a video that i eventually made
on pi day and it's gone to be one of my
most popular videos
and the price for the competition was
this book i suspect they just had a
bunch of copies of this and they needed
to find a prize quickly so they just
gave it to me but um maybe that's
another video if people want to see me
learn about spin waves
what even are they what are magnets how
do they work and then next to all of
these by the way this is the stuff i
haven't read yet
including some wait a minute why is june
in there i'm halfway through
that's where that went also i've got to
show you this um so my friend claire
uh gave me this book for my birthday uh
which is the diversity of life not a
book i probably would have normally
picked up it's a subject i'm interested
in but you know this doesn't
particularly grab me
but look at how beautiful i'll have to
get some close-ups of this
look at how beautiful the volume is and
it's not just on the outside the
the plates on the inside are like the
photography is just
beautiful as well um it's such a good
present like thank you claire because
it's one of my
my favorite books i realized that this
video is too long as it is so i'm very
briefly going to go through some of the
books here
in the personal collection i should
point out by the way that basically i
have a bookcase and pixelgirl has a
bookcase
hers is mostly spanish and french books
because that's
what she's interested in she's a spanish
french teacher so there is yet more but
i cannot claim to have read
most of the stuff in her bookcase up
here at the top we have the warhammer
section i've limited myself to just one
shelf
i have more at my parents house at the
front here we've got the first few books
of the horse heresy series along with
brother for the snake the best
standalone i think
uh entry to 40k uh behind them we have
uh the entire gordon's ghost series out
the way to anarch and then on top
of those kind of appropriately i have
these things these are that's a knife
and that's a bottle opener that i made a
friend of mine stag do we went to a
forge
and we forged him a sword and the rest
of us got to do sort of like little bits
like this i have another knife upstairs
i've actually
shined up so obviously i had to store
these in the most appropriately
metal part of you know literature
next to the 40k books we have the
silmarillion which is a book i would
love to have the courage to read one day
my dad is a huge tolkien fan
and i know he's read it and he found it
difficult
so what do i have and then next to that
we've got what if by randall monroe
the book that i always recommend that
people who are going up for science
interviews at oxford should read
the way that monroe approaches questions
and this is literally how interview
questions
work it's it's a such a good piece of
scicom
oh and lastly axiom's end i'm a big
sucker for
first contact stories star trek first
contact is kind of
one of my guilty pleasure films and i
really enjoyed axiom's end by lindsey
ellis fellow youtuber this middle level
i'm not going to dwell too much on
because actually a lot of these books i
haven't
read a lot of books were sent to me by
people uh you know saying oh could you
would you be interested in reviewing
this
type thing um and some of them i have
talked about before like the
immortal life of henrietta lacks and
quantum um you know some of these are
interesting books just uh two things of
interest firstly this little book on
cajun and saltford now cajun
is my hometown it's where i grew up and
this book is unique in the house because
it was written in part
by my mum she's uh in the credits here
so the first person in my family to be a
an official author which i'm very proud
of the the section she wrote on
the chocolate factory because that's
kind of the one of the only interesting
things about kenjum uh is
really interesting it's a small town but
it's got some nice history and then the
other
thing which has nothing to do with the
content of the book is this copy of
flatland
because if i turn it around it is shot
to hell and the reason for that is
when i was at exeter doing my phd oh god
it's literally got holes in
i had a really cheap bed and the bed
frame just
fell apart and i had to basically
prop up my mattress on piles of books
for a couple of i slept on the floor for
a good couple of months
and unfortunately flatland was on top of
one of those stacks and it just got
ruined by that so i'm very sorry
edwin abbott abbott but it was a noble
sacrifice
and then lastly i'm down on the floor
for these two shelves
uh which i have read basically
everything of this is kind of like a
fantasy shelf down here we've got
uh the entire published to date a song
of ice and fire
and on top of that the book of dust by
philip pullman
yes i do ah on top here i have the
original start materials and if i get
out northern lights
i was lucky enough to meet philip
pullman and
uh he gave a talk at my oxford college
whilst i was there
and he signed my book which
was really cool i feel like a lot of
kids have a fantasy series in particular
like a series of books that kind of
defines their childhood and for a lot of
people that's harry potter and i did
read harry potter i loved it as a kid
but i think his dark materials was my
fantasy
series this was the thing that really
got me going and really got me into into
reading
a whole load of fantastic books on this
shelf actually spqr by merrybeard
phenomenal introduction to classics
the man who mistook his wife for a hat
which i have i talked about in a
relatively recent video
i've linked up all of these book videos
in the description silk roads by pete
francopan as well
and then the collection of john green
books i uh obviously
everybody in the world seems to have
assigned a fault in our stars and the
formula stars is great
young adult fiction i think actually
turtles all the way down
is better i just really like john
green's later books in particular i
think that some of the earlier ones like
an abundance of catherine's is
underrated
um i still need to read his brother's
stuff an absolutely remarkable thing
i i still need to to get around to
reading that i'm sure i will enjoy it
perhaps more interesting on the shelf
are the items in front um
because actually there's three items
they all have different stories first of
all this 3d printed tedx logo
um this was a present when i gave a ted
talk at the university of lancaster
and i asked if i could steal it which i
guess means it's not stealing at all and
the guy who organized the conference
gave it to me so that was a nice little
memento
then this is a tiny model of the eiffel
tower
which doesn't come from france well it
originally comes from france
i was given this in korea when i went to
south korea for a an energy conference
the renewable energy network is
headquartered in paris and so they gave
out kind of goodie bags to all the
people in korea who helped them out
and that included me as a videographer
so i have an eiffel tower
from france via korea and this guy oh
oh that's where the martian went this
lamp however
uh was from when i did some filming with
bbc bite size so this comes from
belfast and basically the way that
when you look at productions uh that are
professionally done they will have
somebody who dresses the set
um and uh for bbc bite size when we were
doing the science revision
their job was to make the set look
science-y and one of the things they did
was to put
this lamp in the background and um
at the end of shooting i stole it
for the sake of completeness by the way
i should mention that i have jasmine
just down
here like an inch from me excuse me
madam are you aware that you are the
most perfect being in the universe
i don't think i don't think she realizes
i also just out of shot down here
there's not a huge amount down here
that's interesting i've got a couple
more textbooks
i've also got youtube planning book for
kids i think this was a christmas
present one year
maybe i should do this on stream and one
last textbook that was really
influential on me
the visual display of quantitative
information which is one of those
textbooks that you're never going to get
set on a science course but everyone
should read because
scientists have to make figures and
there are a ton of bad figures
out there in the world but on the
subject of textbooks come back upstairs
with me
now one of the reasons that i like riley
hobson and ben's and some of these other
textbooks so much is because
yes it contains the knowledge you need
to learn if you read the textbook you
will
learn the math but if you go to the back
of any one of these chapters
it will have dozens of practice problems
including
some hints and some answers if you get
stuck and this is actually how you learn
maths this is how you learn
physics and science and math you do
practice problems you get your hands
dirty
but unfortunately this textbook is like
a brick
and you have to have a whole number of
textbooks if you want to get a decent
number of practice problems
if only there was a solution to that
enter brilliant the educational website
and
app that gets you to learn by doing
using brilliance app or web interface
you can support your learning in the
classroom or
set yourself a challenge to master a new
subject brilliant offers expertly
written courses in a range of subjects
including
chemistry physics mathematics and
computer science which are built
around the concept of learning by
solving problems and learning from your
mistakes
it's much easier to get into a habit of
learning by making the process of
practice
the most important part of learning as
easy as possible
i adore physical textbooks and the smell
of books so i'm never going to replace
all of these but to actually be able to
log onto one website and
to test yourself on everything from
computer science to math to physics
to logic it's really really useful and
the problems are
really good i've said this several times
if i was at school at university
now i would be using brilliant i really
think it is good
whether you're in full-time education or
you want to gift access to a student or
you're out working in the real world but
would like to improve your quantitative
skills
head to brilliant.org simon clark to
sign up the first 200 people to do so
will get 20
off their premium annual subscription
making this a steal
and the best investment you could
possibly make for your brain
thanks to brilliant for sponsoring this
video so there we go
thank you very much for watching i hope
that you enjoyed this tour of various
books
and do let me know if yeah you want to
see me torch myself with
quantum field theory in the future here
is some recommended viewing next some
book stuff and then also some of the
other stuff that i make
if you're new here if you like this
please do subscribe and you know how
this works
like comment share
engagement engagement engagement
engagement thank you very much for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one